[Musique]
nous accueillons ce soir une nouvelle
membre au ca christiane bergevin bonsoir
vous êtes administratrice conseillère
stratégique en énergie services publics
développement durable ou cabinet conseil
roland berger
vous avez été vice présidente chez
desjardins et snc-lavalin
vous avez tout une feuille de route
merci de vous joindre à nous dans notre
village est claire bolduc bonsoir
bonsoir gerald bonsoir christiane
bienvenus bonsoir vont alors parlons
d'internet haute vitesse je vais donner
la parole tchouta clair si vous
permettez parce que l'internet haute
vitesse d'un enjeu pour les régions du
québec
est ce que cette fois ci selon vous
c'est la bonne j'ai un mot un seul mot
et c'est pour les régions et pour les
communautés rurales généralement les
communautés plus éloignés et - dont la
population moins nombreux j'ai un mot
enfin on a tellement souvent annoncé les
projets jeudi à arrêter d'en parler 7 le
maintenant c'est ce qu'on a devant lui
une proposition pour le réaliser c'est
la première fois que les deux
gouvernements s'affichent ensemble et
avec des contrats déjà établis des
ententes déjà établi pour couvrir le
service alors en faillite
et qu'est ce qui est différent cette
fois-ci christiane selon vous je pense
qu'une collaboration qui tu dis qu entre
le québec et le canada ont été les
premiers annoncés cette nouvelle vague
et ce qui est important c'est de se dire
que l'internet la baisse le premier
ministre a dit que c'était comme
l'électricité moi je pense que c'est
comme le téléphone on veut pas s'en
passer
ça amène les soins à domicile ça mène
les soins à distance plus performants
l'éducation et surtout surtout gerald
l'innovation pour toute notre écosystème
de pme qui est un moteur économique pour
le québec et est ce que cette fois ci on
pense que ça va super parce qu'une
guerre des poteaux pendant des années
est ce qu'on pense que cette fois ci ça
va se faire parce qu'il ya claire des
pénalités pour les fournisseurs qui ne
viendra pas il viendra pas honoré leur
contrat
je trouve que c'est une belle innovation
dans la manière d'aborder la question
monsieur premier ministre legault le
mans
ce n'est la question des poteaux étaient
un enjeu régler mais les pénalités sur
la non livraison ou les retards de
livraison
c'est une belle initiative pour
améliorer et à accélérer la desserte par
ailleurs on a parlé de réseau open axis
nous très français je pense qu'on y pas
tout est fait à ce stade ci au canada
oui il ya encore du chemin à faire
c'est la deuxième fois en autant de
semaines ces deuxièmes lundis entre les
premiers ministres legault et trudeau
monsieur trudeau monsieur legault
d'ailleurs qui dit qu'est ce qu'on va se
dire lundi prochain à 10 ans et à la
blague pour faire des annonces
économiques importants christiane est ce
que d'autres dossiers selon vous sur
lesquels ils pourraient où ils auraient
avantage à s'entendre rapidement
absolument gerald la liste est longue
combien tu en as pour répondre je vous
dirais que le domaine du financement des
soins de santé est vraiment un secteur
la population est vieillissante le
québec le demande où on à faire plus
ensemble mais n'oublions pas le logement
social
on a eu une annonce en septembre dernier
collaboration provincial fédéral pour
les hlm pour l'entretien et 3 milliards
sur 10 ans mais est-ce que c'est assez
est ce qu'on pourrait penser à une
enveloppe pour rendre les édifices plus
performants au niveau énergétique par
exemple on sait que se chauffer c'est
une dépense principale des ménages alors
moi je pense que le logement social on
peut faire mieux qu'hier tout le secteur
de l'aéronautique de l'avionique et de
l'aéronautique qui n'a pas bénéficié
jusqu'à ce jour d'être du gouvernement
fédéral
je pense que et on le voit le secteur
est principalement présent au québec il
y a un besoin d'appui de ce secteur look
qui est criant on attend toujours les
personnages du cénacle vous dans votre
mrc vous êtes préfet de la mrc de
témiscamingue est ce qu'il ya des enjeux
de connexions internes ont absolument
absolument oui toutes nos communautés
rurales sont mal desservis on parle
aussi d'un territoire qui est riche très
riche en milieux sont restés en
pourvoirie
alors heureux en à oui on a accueilli
cette nouvelle là avec énormément de
bonheur c'est aussi qui sera le
fournisseur internet chez nous on sait
le besoin qui est présent c'est le
développement économique
et c'est la première fois que deux
premiers ministres assument le
reconnaissent le niveau des sensibilités
de ce service là alors oui on a besoin
et on est heureux de l'annoncer je vous
emmène sur un deuxième sujet ce soir sur
la chine nous qui avons au canada tant
misé sur une relation commerciale depuis
25 ans avec la chine
comment on doit réagir parce qu'on a
voulu développer le commerce l'économie
comment on doit réagir christiane face à
la détention arbitraire de michael
covering de michael power est bon on
verra le résultat du profil mais on
serait pas d'espoir là dessus les
violations des droits de la personne en
particulier le génocide des ouigours que
les parlementaires ont récemment dénoncé
c'est tellement une situation difficile
gérald on as vous avez dit développe une
relation privilégiée entre le canada et
la chine c'est un partenaire important
on a une crise qui dans le fond le
ressemble à celle de tianamen swing il
ya vingt ans je pense que la proche
d'avoir des mesures en coalition avec
d'autres partenaires est une bonne
approche
parce que tout seul on n'y arrivera pas
alors donc il faut dénoncer ces abus là
il faut qu'il y ait des sanctions il
faut surtout qu'ils aient des
représentations diplomatiques importante
et surtout surtout garder le commerce
ouvert parce que le commerce c'est la
capacité d'ouvrir et de garder leur
relation ouverte avec les populations je
comprends mais est ce que l'économie pas
faire deuxième
je vous dirais qu'on doit continuer elle
doit passer aux mêmes plans mais en
appuyant fortement sur une résolution
parce que ça risque de prendre un
certain temps clair on est en chambre et
les corses au canada mais hank l'ambré
les corses dans ce dossier là d'une part
parce qu'on avait une entente
d'extradition qu'on a qu'à nos
partenaires ont demandé d'appliquer
d'autre part parce que ce sont nos
citoyens qui en paient le prix
mais c'est aussi nos entreprises qui ont
des relations commerciales et une
relation d'approvisionnement très
importante avec la chine et le n'importe
quel geste lâche et n'ai plus beaucoup
plus indépendante que le canada
on en importe quel juste que ce soit le
canada aura des conséquences faut être
très prudent
cela dit je rejoins christiane
l'approchent diplomatique sera gagnante
les dents faut continuer à entretenir le
dialogue
alors quelle sorte de sanction dans ces
circonstances diplomatiques économiques
qui ferme le canada peut-il se permet
tout doit-il se permettre d'imposer face
à la chine
moi j'hésite beaucoup
vous savez quand on a eu des sanctions
avec l'afrique du sud dans l'apartheid
les sanctions avec la corée du nord les
sanctions avec le myanmar
on apprend le poids tout seul pour faire
bouger les choses en même temps ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on doit cautionner des
comportements qui sont inacceptables
alors je privilégierai vraiment les
relations diplomatiques le renforcement
sa vie la menace du bâton est souvent
plus importante que le bâton pour y
avoir des alliés forts et je pense que
les états unis dans ce contexte là vont
vraiment être un joueur clé parce qu'on
vit dans un ménage à trois mais
exactement puisque les états unis sont
notre allié puis on sent que
l'administration by donne les tout à
fait et dans le dossier des deux
marqueurs des dents dossier des ouigours
également et dans d'autres dossiers
peut-être sur le plan économique
aussi est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut se
permettre claire d'aller plus loin dans
nos sanctions dans nos exigences envers
la chine
c'est très difficile d'aller plus loin
dans les sanctions par contre la chine
est très sensible à sa réputation et la
sortie aujourd'hui de 22 pays avec le
canada devant le palais de justice à
pékin palais de justice sur papier ce
tonneau justice c'était significatif sur
cette touche la sensibilité chinoise et
c'est peut-être de nature à faire bouger
au que les bouger les autorités gentils
mots très très rapide de vous questionne
sur l'ambassadeur de chine au canada qui
va prononcer une conférence au corps et
une tribune virtuel le 13 avril est ce
que fait partie de celles et ceux qui
approuvent ou désapprouvent cette
invitation
on l'a évité on devrait continuer à le
recevoir
je pense que monsieur johnson est un
interview voir avec un talent
un extraordinaire je suis johnson et qui
ont pourri qui s'adorent je pense que
c'est l'opportunité de poser les
questions on sait qu'il y aura déjà des
lignes qui sont du côté chinois mais de
le recevoir d'écouté et poser les bonnes
questions je pense que c'est important
clair un mot là-dessus oui je sais c'est
chaud et froid mais on ne peut pas ne
pas le recevoir
ça va peut-être donner une carte
diplomatique de plus ou négociateur et
l'attitude de l'assemblée aussi pour
donner un message à l'ambassadeur de la
chine
oui on verra c'est virtuel des fois
c'est un petit peu difficile de passer
son émotion
christiane est clair merci beaucoup
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit